hey youtubers it's Charlie so Daniel bro
was just seen on the set of Captain
America and there's long been rumors
that he is playing Baron Zemo from the
comics so there's gonna be a video all
about the history of that character
there isn't gonna be any Captain America
Civil War at Comic Con but I did want to
do at least one Marvel movie video this
week and real quick heads up new round
of the Marvel giveaway starts right now
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video I'll announce the winner next week
because there probably won't be a lot of
Marvel stuff posting during Comic Con
when most people think of them they
think of masters of evil
Marvel isn't quite ready for that it
would be amazing if they did masters of
evil in a movie but they haven't done
MODOK they're just like a lot of like
the more ridiculous things that they're
working their way up to just wait till
after infinity war and Inhumans then
things will get really ridiculous movie
version of Baron Zemo is probably gonna
be a little bit more like movie version
of Baron von Strucker there are a couple
things about the Baron Zemo character
that makes him work a little bit better
as a young character in these modern
Marvel movies the most notable version
of the character was one of the Nazis
during the 1940s so it's like you know
how do you explain that he's super young
and all these Marvel movies the back
door to that is that the Baron Zemo
title is hereditary he gets passed down
so he has a son if they want to do
flashback they can do Baron Zemo in the
past and they can do Baron Zemo now it's
a masters of evil family affair I know a
lot of people want to see sin sin is the
daughter of the Red Skull in the comics
we haven't seen her on-screen yet but
it's totally possible they could bring
her on to Baron Zemo just seems like
he's gonna beat her to the punch it was
even a thunderbolt story called Zemo
born better where he gets thrown back in
time and he sees all the past
incarnations all the all the people
previously in his family that have held
the Baron Zemo title and in speaking of
time-travel the cool thing about Baron
Zemo is that he involves some of the
mysticism that we're starting to see in
Phase three
a la Doctor Strange in black panther
marvel's done a good job of balancing
its villains with its hero so you bring
in magic heroes you got to bring in
magic villains not that I'm expecting
Baron Zemo to weave a lot of magic just
that the character has a basis in that
so don't be surprised if Baron Zemo is
just as obsessed with Infinity stones in
the tesseract power as Red Skull was
world domination power
who cares which dimension it comes from
one of his defining traits though is the
mask in the costume that he wears like
successive baron zemo's like the sun
they still wear the costume when they
take the title but in the comics the
mask is kind of like a dr. doom
situation where dr. doom wears the mask
to hide his horrible appearance like
it's been scarred by battles they might
end up changing that for the movie just
because women really like to look at
Daniel Bruhl so they don't want to take
that away but they might scar him during
the movie like he might get the mask
during the movie the really big question
is is are they going to tie Baron Zemo
to Red Skull in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe because in the comics they were
totally working together in fact Baron
Zemo is partially responsible for
Captain America originally getting stuck
in the ice the way went down in the
comics is is that that experimental
aircraft at the end of the first Captain
America movie that they take off in the
Captain America crashes that was in
Baron Zemo stronghold in the comics the
movie made it seem like any old
stronghold but Marvel could totally
insert the Baron Zemo of the movies into
that movie they could just call it his
stronghold they could tie into that
event or say that he was part of the red
skulls tesseract experiments if they
really wanted to get logical with it
they could say that this version of
Baron Zemo the one that we see in the
movie is his son like the son of the
Baron Zemo that worked with Red Skull
really the biggest recent story arc in
the last like 10 years or so was Baron
Zemo taking the Masters of evil and
masquerading them as the Thunderbolts
trying to gain the world to trust it was
kind of like Norman Osborn's Dark
Avengers so you can see what you know
why they might not do that in the movie
because they kind of did that with Hydra
where they're like we're gonna take over
the world and save it by controlling it
like that was what Winter Soldier was
all about if there's any character in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe that they
co-opted for a good purpose it's gonna
be Loki during infinity war just do the
thing where the really bad guy turns
good for a brief period before he
double-crosses the heroes again that's
kind of like Baron Zemo in the comics
during Thunderbolts but story devices
like that are just ways that Marvel has
them in the comics of making these
villains a little more complex a little
more morally grey so even if the movies
really simplify the Baron Zemo character
just don't don't expect him to be like a
mustache twirling wine swirling villain
he will have a
eating ideology for saving the world
typically villains like him tend to be
lawful evil so it's like they have a
very specific plan they have a code that
they live by but they're definitely
against the heroes but one of the
biggest things that I do think that they
might integrate into the movie in some
way is that Baron Zemo in the comics is
the person who outed Bucky as the Winter
Soldier to the world during Avengers age
of Ultron Falcon said I've been working
a missing-persons case the Emmys talking
about Winter Soldier so they're gonna
pick that up in Civil War obviously cap
is gonna want to redeem Bucky but a good
way to undermine that would be to out
all the terrible things that he has done
to the world like look at all these
assassinations he's responsible for
killing Kennedy like all these famous
people all over the world it's a really
easy way for Baron Zemo to make the hero
seem just as evil as the villains really
the most fun thing about this is the
Daniel Bruhl is now part of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe like we have Benedict
Cumberbatch like we're getting all these
great actors I would say like one of the
biggest victories Marvel has had in the
last 10 years is their casting hell he
even just did a movie with Thor and
actually Daniel Bruhl was the far better
actor in that movie if you want to watch
it it's actually a pretty fun movie it's
Ron Howard it's about car racing but you
can watch them in inglorious basterds
you can watch them in rush in like
Daniel Bruhl is amazing in most of the
stuff that he does it's hard to find a
bad performance of his which is why
Marvel wanted him so bad let me know the
what comic book stuff from Baron Zemo do
you want to see in the movie it can be
you know funny can be crazy
Marvel is that a really good job of
delivering on all the craziness that
it's promised like like Avengers
infinity war is at the top of the pile
like they're working their way up that
pyramid once we get to next year we'll
see full-blown magic so there's just so
many things to go crazy about and I know
a lot of you're bummed that Marvel isn't
going to comic-con with any footage or
anything like that but ant-man is coming
out like literally the week after that
so they'll have already done all the
marketing that they're probably gonna do
for that so there really isn't any point
for them and they just they don't have
enough for Captain America Civil War yet
Marvel's achieve that rarefied air where
they can make announcements on their own
timetable like they don't have to rely
on Comic Con for awareness or anything
like that which is like the watermark
for big comic-book movies right now
comic-con used to be such a big deal for
movies like it was like oh we got to get
this out otherwise nobody's going to
know about the movie when it comes
but Marvel's gotten so ubiquitous like
until they turn out a really terrible
movie people will just go see it no
matter what in related news they
actually just started to film dr.
strange or they just went to London to
start filming so between now and the end
of the year we should learn a lot more
about that movie so I you guys wait for
the rest of my comic-con stuff to start
posting you can click here from like my
first big comic-con preview and you can
click here to learn all about my top 5
spider-man villains thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you